[Musique]
en
avec mary
j'obtiens du mali on ne respecte pas les
conduire
[Musique]
c'est vrai
c'est juste pour avoir une indifférence
parce que la plupart du temps chaque
matin les parents nous amène chaque
matin le compliqué et des colliers aller
au travail c'est assez drôle de clés
pour les parents dont couleurs passées
courtage ans prétend avoir du mal de
repères et pour avoir la liste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
asseyez la commune de coqs en général
c'est pas la crise il en europe pour que
ça soit scellée par français c'est que
nous appliquons ce truc nous appelons
c'est cette place de nouvelles de nos
examens c'est cette batterie nous
travaillons mais à la pratique le corps
sur place dans la ville maintenant ça
c'est une autre réalité
[Musique]
si l'écart était
de rouler doucement malgré tout
seulement voilà lancé